[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en tant qu'être multi cellulaire nous
tirons tous nos origines de ce mélange
d'eau et d'une matière érodée plus ou
moins carbonée ou azoté qu'on appelle la
terre
donc l'eau dans le sol on en vient mais
ce qu'on a aussi beaucoup plus de mal à
admettre c'est que même encore
aujourd'hui on en dépend entièrement
quand je vous parle du sol je vous parle
bien de la couche la plus superficielle
de la cour route terrestre qui est
encore influencé par les conditions de
surface donc l'eau et l'air et non pas
des couches plus profondes qui sont
qu'on appelle souvent la roche mère et
qui sont là plus tu ressors de la
géologie ou de l'hydrogéologie
donc dans ces quelques premiers
centimètres ou mettre du sol la matière
est formée soit par l'érosion de la
roche mère soit par dépose sédimentaire
issus de la faune et de la flore
techniquement
on dit que les sols sont des milieux
poreux c'est à dire qu'ils sont
constitués de blocs et de particules
séparés par des vides des pores
et ces milieux pour eux on les connaît
très mal et on a souvent tendance à les
négliger à considérer qu'il se passe pas
grand chose et que c'est juste une
interface entre l'atmosphère et la
géologie
alors qu'en fait
il se passe énormément de processus dans
les sols et en particulier pour le
stockage et le transfert de l'eau
il y a une matière qui compose les sols
et que j'affectionne particulièrement en
tant que céramiste c'est l'argile
l'argile ce sont les particules les plus
fines qui constituent les sols avec des
tailles de particules plus petites que
deux micromètres et pour atteindre cette
taille les particules d'argile ont des
structures en feuillets des feuillets de
silicates d'alumine hydratée qui ont
eux-mêmes des propriétés électroniques
qui leur permettent de s'agencer entre
eux
et cette agencement des feuillets quand
on travaille l'argile on se rend compte
que c'est pas anodin en tant que
céramiste on parle souvent du caractère
d'une argile par là on entend d'abord
son état de densité ou d'humidité si
elle est plutôt sèche et dure au
contraire molle et humide
mais aussi et surtout sa plasticité
c'est à dire la manière dont elle va
pouvoir transmettre les mouvements qu'on
lui propose avec les mains
il y a des argiles qu'on y répond
simples et très rapides au mouvement des
mains alors qu'il y a d'autres qui ont
des réponses beaucoup plus complexes
comme la porcelaine par exemple
et cette plasticité de l'argile
elle dépend à la fois du type de
feuillets qu'on rencontre dans l'argile
mais aussi de leur agencement
c'est-à-dire de leur histoire de leur
vécu qui les a amenés à un tel
agencement
l'argile c'est un vecteur d'émotion
incroyable à son contact on peut avoir
des émotions enfouies refoulées ou même
des moments de l'enfance qui peuvent
ressurgir je dis souvent que en tournage
quand on tourne la terre nos antennes
toutes les 10 petites antennes qu'on a
au bout des doigts
deviennent comme un sismographe de nos
états internes c'est à dire que nos
émotions vont être directement
retranscrites et imprimé sur l'argile et
ça c'est incroyable
alors pourquoi on développe une telle
sensibilité au contact de l'argile
mon hypothèse c'est le rapport à la
chair
j'ai calculé que la densité moyenne de
l'argile dans laquelle on la travaille
habituellement c'est à peu près la même
que la densité moyenne du corps humain
et puis il y a aussi que ce lien entre
l'argile et la chair humaine il est
sacralisé dans énormément de croyances
de mythologie de religion et même dans
la Bible quand on étudie les sols et
leur contribution au débit des rivières
on se rend compte que les sols
fonctionnent comme des éponges
qui sont capables de stocker de l'eau et
de la rétribuer peu à peu
avec des temps de stockage variables
mais entre quelques jours et plusieurs
mois on parle de l'effet tampon des sols
et le fait qu'il y ait de l'eau dans les
rivières même en l'absence de
précipitation pendant plusieurs mois va
alors entièrement dépendre de la
capacité des sols d'un bassin versant à
stocker l'eau et la rétribuer petit à
petit alors il y a plusieurs critères
qui font que une infiltration peut bien
se produire le premier c'est que plus
le flux est lent
mieux se fait l'infiltration
alors pour ça la végétation à être
beaucoup à ralentir le flux de pluie en
interceptant les gouttes d'eau qui
arrivent avec les feuilles
il y a aussi des critères sur la
compacité et l'épaisseur des sols et là
encore la végétation va aider en aérant
et en décompactant les sols via le
système racinaire et au contraire le
piétinement
et surtout le piétinement bovin va
beaucoup compacter les sols et là
vraiment limité l'infiltration donc pour
toutes ces raisons
un sol végétalisé va beaucoup mieux
infiltrer qu'un seul nu
et là on voit apparaître ce qu'on
appelle une boucle de rétroaction c'est
à dire que un sol moins végétalisé 20
mois infiltré donc sur un moins sec donc
sera moins végétalisé donc un filtre à
moins donc sera moins sec donc sera
moins végétalisé etc etc
et c'est dans ce cycle dans cette boucle
de rétroaction qu'on veut surtout pas
rentrer pour nous
les humains
le meilleur endroit
ou peut-être l'eau
c'est dans les sols
alors il y a beaucoup de politique
publique ou politique d'aménagement qui
en ce moment qui vise à assécher les
sols à les drainer pour pouvoir les
exploiter pour l'agriculture ou la
construction et puis à stocker l'eau
dans des réservoirs étanches en fait on
adore drainer les sols on a l'impression
que si on prend la l'eau dans la terre
on va gagner de l'eau
alors qu'en fait c'est exactement
l'inverse qui va se passer
c'est à dire que quand on draine un sol
il va se passer un processus d'appel
d'air ou en l'occurrence d'appel d'eau
qui va faire que l'ensemble des sols du
bassin versant vont être aussi être
asséchés
et donc les cours d'eau vont être
sous-alimentés la végétation va être
placée en difficulté et c'est l'ensemble
du cycle hydrologique qui va être
déréglé
quand on draine un sol
qu'on la sèche ou qu'on l'imperméabilise
avec de l'asphalte non seulement on
grille notre joker protection naturelle
contre les événements extrêmes mais
c'est même la base de notre système
d'avocrovisionnement en eau qu'on va
s'appeler
il y a un concept
qui est en train d'émerger dans la
communauté des hydrologues et que j'aime
beaucoup
c'est l'hydrologie régénérative alors
l'hydrologie régénérative c'est un angle
de vision des sciences hydrologiques qui
proposent de régénérer les cours d'eau
par des aménagements qui mettent au
centre les sols l'eau dans le sol et la
végétation concrètement ce serait par
exemple la construction ou la réflexion
de ce qu'on appelle des nous ou des
baissières en fonction des régions
qui sont ces fossés poreux et
végétalisés situés en amont des
parcelles agricoles qui permettent de
ralentir les flux et donc d'améliorer
l'infiltration et de limiter le
ruissellement et l'érosion de surface
et bien sûr
la revégétalisation massive
des espaces anthropisés
donc c'est à partir
de l'eau dans le sol
que peut se régénérer ainsi que
l'hydrologique
et c'est drôle parce que je vais vous
parler tout à l'heure du rapport à la
chair qui évoque l'argile
et puis il y a cette métaphore qu'on
fait souvent que
l'eau et les rivières sont comme le sang
et les veines de la terre
et avec cette métaphore
l'origine du monde
sont les milieux pour eux
remplis d'eau
les zones humides
rempli de sang
les places en
vous voyez en montagne au printemps
ce moment où la neige a commencé à
fondre puis il y en a plus assez pour
faire du ski puis il y a encore trop
pour faire de la rando ou bien cette
petite brune fine qui vous trempe
jusqu'à l'os quand vous entendez le bus
ou même ces berges du lac rempli de bout
et de roseaux qui vous empêchent de vous
baigner ou même encore pour
l'agriculteur ou l'agriculture triste
cette zone humide autour de la source
dans lesquelles les vaches s'enlisent et
puis qu'il aimerait bien drainer
et ben
toutes ces situations qui nous sont si
désagréables
paradoxalement
elles ne sont fondamentales c'est quand
même fou qu'on déteste autant quelque
chose dont on dépend entièrement
ce que je vous invite à faire à partir
de maintenant
c'est d'aimer tous ces moments
d'aimer la pluie d'aimer la bruine
d'aimer la boue d'aimer la neige
collante et d'avoir l'humilité de
reconnaître que toutes ces situations
elles sont fondamentales à notre survie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]